hello
everyone and welcome to today's
presentation part of agilent's virtual
energy and chemical summit
i am abby pell of lab roots and i will
be your moderator for today's event
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind
everyone that this is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions you would
as you would like during the
presentation to do so
simply click and type them into the ask
a question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the ask the
question box
located on the far left of your screen
i now present today's speaker george
gonzalez
agilent standard test program and enter
an overview addressing required testing
in energy and chemicals for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
george you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone my name is george
gonzalez
i work for agilent technologies this
presentation
is going to provide an overview
of how agilent is working with customers
through collaboration in the development
of standard test methods
at agilent our goal is to deliver
scientific
operational and economic value for your
lab
in addition to providing reliable and
robust instruments
we are collaborating with customers
towards the development of new standard
test methods
agilent is currently sponsoring numerous
standard test methods at astm and other
standard development organizations
the development and publication of a new
standard requires
approximately two to three years
i will review the process later in this
presentation
agilent is committed to collaborating
with customers
in the development of new standards we
will now review the mpaes
standards development program as an
example
we will also review a few other agilent
sponsored standards
currently in various steps in the
development
agilent introduced the microwave plasma
atomic emission spectrometer or mpaes
recently and the decision was made
to establish a standard test method
at astm
we then moved to collaborate to develop
two standards based on the mpaes
one was for the elemental analysis
of crude oil and residual fuel oil
the second proposed standard is for
the elemental analysis of biodiesel
we coordinated and established a
collaboration task group which included
12 laboratories as shown on the top
right
the global collaboration team then ran
a pilot study and a full
intra-laboratory study
over the course of two and a half to
three years
as shown on the bottom left the timeline
essentially started
with the conception of the idea back in
april of 2017
then we informally introduced the
technique
at a technical presentation at a june
meeting of astm d2
subcommittee 3 meeting and requested
some work items
for the program and move forward
the timeline follows the traditional
astm standard development program
and it flows through establishing the
task group
proceeding on to
preparing a sample set moving on to
running a pilot study determining
and scoping out the full
intra-laboratory study
based on the pilot study results and
then moving into
the promulgation stage of the
proposed standards and i will show
and preview some of the astm
procedural promulgation procedures
later in this presentation
i would like to briefly review the
organizational structure
at astm astm is formed by numerous
technical committees
and the one we have been focusing on
today is
astm d2 which is the
committee on petroleum products liquid
fuels and lubricants
this committee is formed by
four different types of subcommittees
which include the
executive subcommittee a product
subcommittees which are defined as
the letter designations for example d2d
is the committee on hydrocarbons for
chemical and special uses
and then there are property
subcommittees
which are focusing on test methods
for example d2 subcommittee 3
is for elemental analysis and then there
are
a few coordinating subcommittees now if
you notice there
within each subcommittee there are
task groups which are formed to work
on astm standards they're issued
normally by a work item which is a
focus on establishing a new standard
next i would like to review the standard
development process
at astm new standards are typically
justified
by industry need or new technology
the proposed test method is presented in
concept
to the appropriate committee if
sufficient
interest is found a task group is formed
to develop the standard
the task group then drafts the test
method and performs a pilot study
if the test method is found viable the
pilot study data
is used to develop an intra-laboratory
study
which is required to establish test
method precision
and bias upon completion the proposed
test
method is balloted with subcommittee
approval
after ballot if the ballot
passes without any negative votes the
test method moves on to main committee
balloting
however if the ballot incurs
negative votes then the concern needs to
be adjudicated
to determine a concern and whether
it's persuasive or non-persuasive if the
negative vote is found persuasive
the test method must be revised and
re-balloted at subcommittee
if the negative vote is found
non-persuasive through the
adjudication process the test method
moves on
to main committee balloting main
committee
balloting is performed the same way
negative votes are addressed using the
same procedure described above
if the ballot passes without any
negative votes
the test method moves on to the
review by committee on standards
followed by publication
the collaboration program i described
earlier
provided a new test method
astm d 8322 elemental analysis of crude
oil by mpaes
the official title is standard test
method for
determination of elements in residual
fuels
and crude oils by microwave plasma
atomic emission spectroscopy
this work as noted earlier
was completed through a collaboration
which included 12 labs
there are no other standard test methods
for the mpas in the industry
so this provides an opportunity for our
customers to
use the mpaes for commercial trade
and testing of residual fuel oil
and crude oil
standard test method d8322
provides some excellent detection range
capabilities
the valid test result range for each
type of
sample crude oil and residual fuel oil
in this case were determined through
an interlaboratory study
i think you will agree that the test
result
range shown here for each type of sample
meets or exceeds industry standards for
elemental analysis
so agilent's test method development
program included
elemental analysis of biodiesel by mpaes
this work item 56916
has progressed to
subcommittee level and is currently
being balloted
i am currently addressing a couple of
items
that were of concern to some
voting members the standard
is currently balloted and i
believe it will move on to main
committee
later this year and published in the
fall of this year
this slide provides some insight to mpas
performance
in testing biodiesel blends up to b100
again that's biodiesel blends from b1
to b100 the table shown
below contain the balloted test method
valid test result range
for elemental analysis of biodiesel
the valid test result range obtained by
performing the ils
meets or exceeds the current industry
testing performance
and i believe you will agree that the
mpaes
is an excellent instrument for testing
biodiesel blends from b1 to b100
we have also been collaborating with
customers
to revise astm d7845
it's for the determination of chemical
species
in marine fuel oil by gcms
the scope of work is to establish
precision and bias
for this standard by
running an ils in addition
we have also incorporated two new
examples of dean switch systems into
this next revision the revision has been
approved
but pending the precision and bias
information precision and bias
is being established by an ils which is
currently ongoing
the two new examples of dean's switch
have been
incorporated into the existing standard
along with minor editorial revisions
work item 50453
currently in being valid at
astm d2 committee is going to include a
revision
to include new dean switch
configurations which are available with
agilent gcs
the diagram on the left is an example of
a simplified dean switch
which vents to the splitter vent and
uses
our purged ultimate union
the diagram on the right allows for
fast back flush timing and uses
agilent's
cft these configurations will be
incorporated into the next revision of
astm
d7845 and i expect them to be
this standard to be published later in
the fall
of this year
another test method revision for d7845
is for the expansion of scope
for this standard
the expansion will include an extended
capability for additional compounds
that have been requested by iso 8217
specifications
we are currently collaborating with
intertek
which will provide the laboratory gcms
and other materials for us to work
together in the development of
what will essentially become procedure b
of d7845 in a future revision
in addition the work will require a full
intra-laboratory study
and we will require at least 10
laboratories
to establish the full precision
this work is ongoing and as noted in the
other examples
the work requires two to three years
to complete when we will see
the standard revised and published
with the expansion of scope
recently i also worked on the
development
of a test method for determination of
oxygenates in motor gasoline by gcms
in this case it would be an addition or
revision
of astm d5769
which is the test method for
determination of benzene
and total aromatics in motor gasoline
the scope of this method would
incorporate the oxygenates
into d5769
the work performed included the use of
an intubal
gcms and the robustness study
and collaboration was conducted at
bureau veritas
at the houston technical center
in pasadena texas the collaboration has
gone well
and i have presented this proposed test
method
at astm
and going forward we plan to conduct
a full laboratory interlaboratory
study
so to further expand on the scope of the
proposed test
method for determination of oxygenates
in motor gasoline by gcms
you'll see this table includes the
essentially the calibration standards
that were used to
expand the scope and establish the test
method
for this technique the range
in this case is
exactly the same as astm d5599
astm d5599 is a test method
which uses a gcofid
and is the current standard accepted
method by the us epa
in this case you see that all of the
oxygenates meet
the industry requirement for
determination of oxygenates and motor
gasoline
the difference is that we are using a
gcms
the proposed test method has been
presented at astm
and has been accepted to proceed
to revision of astm d5769
to incorporate oxygenates in motor
gasoline
this concludes my presentation on
agilent sponsored
astm standards however as i noted
we are committed to collaborating with
our customers towards the development of
new standards
as well as you might have noticed that
we are
also working on the revision of numerous
standards
so moving forward we will need
volunteers
to help us work on the development of
new standards
and revision of standards which the work
will also include
intra-laboratory studies if you are
interested in participating
please feel free to contact me if you
have any questions or comments
also feel free to contact me directly
thank you for your time today i hope you
have a great day
start the q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now or just click the ask a
question box located on the far left
of your screen now let's get started
the first question is is are ils
studies limited to the us
hi abby no astm
is an international organization and so
we
quite often participate uh have
laboratories participating globally
from basically all parts of the world
so the answer is no
okay all right thank you and
uh how can ha another question we have
is how do we get involved
with an ils study
well the the interested
parties can go to the astm website and
then
search for subcommittees and technical
committees
and then browse down to the standards
under
the jurisdiction of each subcommittee
you will see the standards listed as
well
at the bottom towards the end of the
list you will see
a number of work items as i mentioned in
the presentation
there's some work items that were
referenced
you can simply log in there and
send it it will send an email to the
task group a technical contact and
then you can begin the discussion that
way
thank you george um another question
uh third question here is actually from
william barber
and the question is is ox
oxena jade sorry in d5769
any expected time that this will be
approved
so as as a it's a
it's it's not an easy answer and and i
tried to
sort of elaborate uh some of that in the
process
required to establish a standard in this
case d5769 is an established standard
and and so it should proceed along
a little bit faster than uh than
normal and normal as i mentioned it may
take up to three years before
um the standard is is a new standard
is uh published so in this case uh
roughly
uh about two years and of course
i still need to present a technical
report
and request a work item and
i don't expect the work item to be
requested until
june of 2021 next year so
we're looking at about maybe three years
from now at the soonest
but uh be on the lookout i do plan to
uh publish an application note on that
determination of oxygenates and motor
gasoline in the next few months
thank you george and our last question
here
that we have um is do we have to be a
member of
astm to participate in the study
no you do not as well as the earlier
answer you can
simply contact the technical contact
under the workout item or you can
contact astm.org
and and someone will direct you to
the correct technical contact get
involved now
you still should go to find the work
item that you would like to get involved
with
and if you have a laboratory uh you know
there will be a you know a question and
answer to make sure that the laboratory
is suited
to uh participate in the study
and thank you again george for that
answer um
i want to i think that result or that is
our
questions for today if there are no more
um uh i just want to thank you
for your time today at mr gonzalez and
your important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us
again and questions submitted during the
on-demand period
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
uh this webcast can be viewed on demand
through
november of 2021 and until next time
thank you so much goodbye thank you abby